here's your weekend tickets yes sir a  loving couple faces new threats in Fifty  Shades freed please stop speaking of my  husband as if I weren't here Anna you  may call me mrs. grey you ever just feel  like life is just pushing us towards  something based on a true story the 1517  to Paris follows the American soldiers  who discovered a terror plot on a train  I can't think of one thing that could  stop our fun in Peter Rabbit a new  farmer battles against rabbits tempted  by his vegetable garden his face was so  classic see what's hot in theaters with  this week's fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  you  [Music]